et pour parler de cette épidémie
coronavirus consonnes avec jonathan
peterschmitt médecins généralistes
atteint du corona virus en direct de
bernwiller en alsace bonsoir jonathan tu
fais taire schmitter je rappelle que
vous êtes toujours confiné chez vous
depuis maintenant plusieurs jours
première question comment allez vous et
alors pour le coup moi je vais mais
plutôt bien c'est vrai que les journées
sont un peu à peu l'ont parfois la
maison avec plusieurs enfants donc
peut-être un peu de fatigue due aux
enfants mais mon état de santé personnel
est plutôt bon je suis effectivement
testé positif effectivement comme
plusieurs membres de ma famille même
élargi on est maintenant 18 dans ma
famille être effectivement positif mais
mais voilà pour le coup notre état de
santé représentent un petit peu ce que
l'on va retrouver dans la plupart des
quatre coronavirus c'est à dire que ce
seront des symptômes qui ne seront pas
forcément très important alors on va y
revenir sur ce point extrêmement
important qui va certainement rassurer
beaucoup mais j'aimerais vous poser une
question vous dites plusieurs membres de
votre famille est contaminée je crois
savoir que dans votre famille à certains
de vos enfants qui ne l'ont pas été
comment on explique justement on dit que
c'est très très contagieux est ce qu'il
ya des organismes qui peut-être sont
plus résistants que d'autres même en
contact du virus alors là c'est une très
bonne question puisque bon je pense qu'a
posteriori on pourra y répondre sur le
plan virologique là il est beaucoup trop
tôt je pense pour être très précis
là-dessus par contre ce qui est certain
c'est que le prélèvement lui même étant
d'un prélèvement qui est douloureux un
prélèvement qui est difficile notamment
chez les enfants est parfois compliqué
d'être d'être certain que le prélèvement
soit concluant donc dans ma famille j'ai
trois des enfants qui ne sont pas
considérés comme positifs mais qui par
défaut sont quand même considéré comme
étant comme étant contaminée tout
simplement parce qu'ils sont déjà en
contact avec nous et que le prélèvement
était un moment difficile à réaliser
pour eux alors vous dites vous quand
vous parlez de vos s'entendre
même en tant que médecin vous auriez pu
croire à un simple virus de saison alors
la question elle est toute simple c'est
qu'est-ce que clairement ça veut dire
que le bilan des contaminations qu'on
égrène un chaque jour à skis il est
largement sous-estimé sedan vous alors
je dirais que c'est
c'est un point qui effectivement attire
beaucoup l'attention puisque bien
entendu on est on est très attentifs aux
chiffres
sauf que dans l'état actuel des choses
il faut savoir que la question du
dépistage n'est plus la priorité du tout
pourquoi parce que organise un dépistage
pour du coronavirus c'est des
précautions qui sont très importantes
j'ai été très encadrée lors de mon
dépistage et réaliser ça pour quelques
personnes quand on a l'impression que
l'épidémie peut-être en train de prendre
pied quelque part c'est possible mais
réaliser ça à l'échelle de ce qui est en
train de se passer dans la région
mulhousienne
actuellement c'est quelque chose qui
devient impossible et qui au delà des
possibilités n'est plus forcément
quelque chose de très nécessaire puisque
à l'échelle de l'individu
le dépistage ne changera pas grand chose
le dépistage c'est d'abord pour faire un
état des lieux une sorte de photographie
de la santé en général
alors clairement là où je voulais en
venir cecily à son estimation du taux de
contaminer ça veut dire peut-être aussi
qu'il ya une mortalité moins élevé qu'on
veut bien le dire
l oms vous parlez de 3,4 pour cent mais
sur des cas finalement de contamination
connue s'il ya beaucoup plus de cas ça
veut dire que la mortalité moins élevé
je sincèrement s'il faut aller à le
creuser dans cette direction je suis
tout à fait d'accord puisque
effectivement les dépistages seront
maintenant concentrés probablement
surtout sur les personnes qui vont avoir
un état de santé altérée
maintenant je pense bien que dans les
agences et ensuite j'en suis même
confiant et sûr dans les agences
régionales de santé chez mes confrères
épidémiologistes cette frange de
patients qui vont être considérée comme
malade et qui ne seront pas des pc est
prise en considération puisque c'est
c'est le même système dans tous types
d'infection de ce genre là donc oui
sous-estimation on pourrait on pourra
utiliser ce terme là mais je pense que
cette sous-estimation est déjà rentré
dans les dents les tableurs puisque
c'est habituellement comme ça que ça se
passe dans ce type d
bon c'est rassurant effectivement pour
la question de la mortalité mais c'est
délicat sur ce type de virus et qu' il
ne faut pas le sous-estimer puisque les
cas les cas graves ne sont pas ne sont
pas si rares
j'ai moi même dans ma famille de
personnes qui ont dû être hospitalisés
du fait d'un état de santé préoccupant
mais à côté de ça il faut rappeler
l'essentiel à des personnes seront comme
moi aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'elles ne
seront pas plus atteintes dans leur
santé
et c'est justement en direction des
personnes fragiles qu'il va falloir se
concentrer et donc essayer de laisser
toute la place à ces personnes pour
pouvoir leur laissait finalement la
possibilité d'être pris en charge ce que
je me suis évoqué à moi-même cet après
midi c'est que ce n'est pas le nom de la
maladie qui fait la gravité de cette
dernière c'est l'état de santé de la
personne et vous pourrez pas raté un
court les rues grave puisque vous ne
pouvez pas rater des difficultés
respiratoires une filière très
importante et simplement une altération
de l'état général ce n'est pas possible
puisque c'est quelque chose qui se voit
ça emmanuel macron nous dit aujourd'hui
qu'a priori une épidémie est inévitable
un expert qui était à l'elysée évoque
deux à trois semaines avant le stade iii
aujourd'hui vous en tant que médecin
quelles sont les mesures qui vous
paraissent les plus indispensables la
priorité aujourd'hui pour éviter
justement le pire peut-être alors
sincèrement à mon échelle et au vu du
nombre de cadets qui est je suis je suis
informée à notre échelle ici locale je
suis je suis moi et tout à fait d'accord
je l' ai appris là on vous écoutant tout
à l'heure que monsieur mac on parlait
d'une épidémie qui était inévitable
c'est simplement parce que l'épidémie
est déjà est déjà sûre sur place je veux
dire toutes les toutes les conditions
sont réunies
c'est le virus comme dans la plupart des
pathologies de ce genre là à un coude
avance tout simplement parce que à
partir du moment où vous avez compris
qu'il est en train de se développer
il est déjà plus loin donc finalement
l'épidémie bien entendu elle va se
développer bien d'avoir de très nombreux
cas qui vont être déclarées il faut s'y
attendre puisque c'est effectivement
quelque chose qui est quasiment logique
dans cette dans cette dynamique là
maintenant ce qui me semble très
important c'est vraiment cette idée là
que une épidémie aussi large soit elle
doit être doit être contenue au magicien
de ce qu'on peut faire d'où le fait d
quarantaine ou plutôt des cartes des
14èmes dans mon cas pour essayer
d'éviter quand même d'atteindre des
personnes qui ne seraient pas atteinte
on arrivera peut-être pas effectivement
à empêcher le stade le fameux stade iii
dont on parle beaucoup mais est ce que
c'est vraiment la question je me dis
c'est surtout essayé chacun à son
échelle
quand il ya un doute quand il y a une
certitude de contacter des symptômes les
personnes doivent rester chez elles
souhaitent être confiné tout simplement
pour éviter de propager le virus mais au
delà de sa laisse et surtout aussi
l'accès libre aux patients qui sont dans
un état plus plus important en essayant
justement d'éviter d'encombrer les
lignes du 15 ici en alsace ne sont plus
joignables et n'est plus possible pour
mission de vous couper parce qu'on
arrive à la fin et on est obligé de
rendre pour donner votre avis jacques
sapir pu s'installer merci à vous en
tout cas d'avoir été avec nous et dans
quelques instants